I want to take a few minutes today to
tell you a little bit about one of our
sponsors here on the show and it's a
company that I'm really glad that we're
working with because they're providing a
really elegant solution to a real-world
problem and the problem is that a lot of
people don't even understand Bitcoin and
cryptocurrency even like on a
fundamental level like how to get it
what to do with it and everybody has
their own opinion on the sort of
economic philosophy behind Bitcoin and
the price fluctuations that we've been
seeing and people are entitled to and
should have those opinions but the
average person should at least have a
way of obtaining and storing and using
Bitcoin and crypto and understanding how
it works if they want to without all of
the barriers that often exist like
people not knowing enough about how it
works to acquire cryptocurrency they
don't know enough about the technology
and what BRD does is make the entire
process simple for people with
experience but probably more importantly
people who are brand-new to it whether
its buying cryptocurrency storing it
keeping it safe so for most of the
general public a bitcoin is still a
mystery there was a recent PwC survey
which found that only 6% of Americans
consider themselves to be either very
familiar or extremely familiar with
crypto currencies eighty-three percent
said they are only slightly familiar or
not familiar at all but despite the
average person's uncertainty maybe about
what bitcoin is or how it works or how
they could integrate it into their life
if they want to or into their finances
if they want to there's a huge amount of
curiosity about it among average people
as well they're not just writing it off
as something that's totally irrelevant
or uninteresting most people seem to at
least recognize the technological
innovation it required that it's sort of
turned our traditional conceptions about
what money is upside down in some ways
and people are paying attention to the
entire phenomenon of Bitcoin becoming so
popular dim popular and prevalent in the
discussion Google Trends shows that
searches for Bitcoin far outnumber
searches for things like Google Wallet
or Apple pay and Samsung pay but I think
that the root of the mass adoption
problem that Bitcoin has why the public
at large is not adopting it as fast as
people who believe in Bitcoin would hope
is probably because it's a new
innovation of computer science and some
of bitcoins most fundamental aspects are
intertwined with the technology and it
can be admittedly difficult for people
to actually just get some Bitcoin if
they want to to know what to do with it
once they have it how to use it to pay
for things if that's what they want to
do and so on and it's not even
necessarily just Bitcoin itself it's
cryptocurrency its blockchain as
emerging technologies most people have
not fully wrapped their heads around how
a currency can be decentralized how and
why transactions are immutably Ledyard
or what a blockchain even is or what
that means most exchanges that exist
where one can go buy Bitcoin and other
Kryptonian
more intricate knowledge about trading
and how it all works and then you've got
to know where to store the crypto you
don't know whether it's going to be safe
am I going to get hacked
how would hacking even work so unless
there's a way to make the adoption of
crypto simpler and easier to start with
Bitcoin is probably going to be stuck in
this state where it's only being used by
the more tech savvy people or trading
and investing enthusiasts and if Bitcoin
is going to really take off and we don't
know if it is every day people need to
take advantage of portals to the
cryptocurrency space that exist which do
allow regular people to participate
which gets us to BRD which is a company
that wants to be a simplifier in the
crypto asset industry because their core
focus is just making it as effortless as
possible for everyday consumers to
migrate
the world of cryptocurrency by offering
the BRD mobile wallet which is a mobile
app or Android and iOS which allows you
to buy sell trade store send and receive
crypto currencies like Bitcoin Bitcoin
cash aetherium long list of others as
well you can buy crypto using other
crypto or using a credit card using
physical Bitcoin ATMs and the interface
is designed with beginners in mind so
it's really easy to use everything is
kept simple really clean the way Aaron
from BRD was framing it the other day
when we were talking he said BRD is the
app that you would use to introduce your
grandma to Bitcoin at the Thanksgiving
dinner table and that's true with BRD to
buy sell hold crypto all you really need
to know is how to use a smart phone and
as I said there are a lot of Bitcoin
beginners who don't know the best place
to keep their Bitcoin whether they're
doing it correctly is it going to stay
safe am I using a secure platform
storing your crypto on BRD wallet is
completely free security and privacy
were the top priority for BRD when they
designed the app everything's completely
decentralized which means there aren't
any BRD servers that are going to get
hacked causing your crypto to get stolen
and I know that privacy is also a
concern for many people in our audience
and with BRD there aren't even accounts
or usernames or passwords you remain
totally anonymous as a user Aaron from
BRD was telling us about it the other
day nobody but you has access or
visibility into your funds or
transactions meaning BRD doesn't even
know the names of its customers so if
you have an issue with the way facebook
is using your data and monetizing it
without your your permission or or
blessing think about a company like BRD
that literally doesn't even have any
data on its customers in the first place
yes so when you use the BRD wallet all
you have is a 12 word key which is
virtually hack proof I thought it was
interesting how Aaron from BRD sort of
put it into perspective for us yeah it's
it's pretty mind-blowing so
if you were to take so the this these 12
words this sort of root password if you
will each each slot has I think it's
2048 available words so there's a word
list and then it's one of these 2000
words for each slot now if you ask a
computer to crack a one-word password
that's 2000 words possibility it's gonna
take a fraction of a fraction of a
second so it is with two words or three
words or four words but when you get to
twelve words you're looking at crazy
numbers such as if we turn if we took
all the matter in our solar system and
turn it into a supercomputer a thousand
times as efficient as the best computer
we have today and let it run until the
heat death of the universe it still
would not crack your password so we get
into some really astronomical numbers
that are almost impossible to comprehend
but the short the short version is it's
secure and BRD is just as useful for
anyone who does have a lot of experience
with crypto because BRD offers just
about anything you'd want in a platform
that offers these types of services they
just do it in a really sleek and
straightforward way that makes it easier
to use it's one of the oldest and
largest crypto wallets in the world it
was founded in 2014 it was the first
Bitcoin wallet in the iOS App Store ever
these guys have been around for a while
they know what they're doing and today
BRD has over two million users and over
six billion dollars in cryptocurrency is
being stored on the platform as of right
now the app is more popular than ever
the last quarter of 2018 was their
biggest quarter ever almost 400,000 new
users and in 2018 last year they doubled
their user base users from more than 170
countries are on the app available in 14
languages top 50 finance app in the App
Store in major regions like the US UK
and Canada and it's a top 100 finance
app in 75 percent of the world BRD says
that they don't think banks are the
enemy
but that everybody should have ownership
over their finances and that the real
mistake is thinking that there's no way
opt out of the current financial system
if you really wanted to I would strongly
urge you to check out BRD wallet they
are strong supporters of the David
Pakman show their only goal is to make
Bitcoin and cryptocurrency more
accessible and easier to use and they've
made a really awesome app to accomplish
exactly that if you have Bitcoin give
BRD a try if you've been thinking about
experimenting with it
BRD is great to get started I've put a
link underneath this video you can also
check out my interview with Aaron from
BRD I've put a link to that underneath
the video as well